hey everyone diavolo here and in today's
video we're diving into another
absolutely brutal yet visually beautiful
manga called Diego karaku or hell's
Paradise which takes place during the
Edo period And it wield much the same as
our own throughout the first of these
four arcs that we're going to look into
we dive into the workings of this cruel
naruto-iss Japanese world where we
follow the story of a vicious assassin
named Gabby Maru and his journey in
order to gain freedom the story is
absolutely dope its themes are top tier
its art is visually the most stunning of
the dark Trio and I've had so much more
fun than expected unraveling just how
fine-tuned it really is jigo kuraku is
effectively a blend of two Japanese
words jigoku and Goku kuraku Heathen and
Hell the whole idea of Good and Evil
plays out in so many different ways and
it really just leaves you there thinking
on it re-reading wanting to understand
the underlying message States actually
being told to you so without further Ado
push this video to 5K likes for the next
part and subscribe so I know that you
want the rest of the series either way
sit back and relax as we dive into the
first Arc of Yuki kaku's how Paradise
as we kick things off we find a young
restrained man who's just been betrayed
by his comrades on a recent Mission
before bringing this sword down he asks
some for any passing words but the
infamous Gabby Morrow the hollow simply
replies nah so you see decapitation
demands exemplary sword Technique One in
which only a few have ever been able to
master typically the spectacle turns
into a brute Fierce that transforms the
grounds into an arena of Hell however as
this sword comes down atop Gabby Maro it
leaves everyone absolutely blown away
once it snaps and collectors to the
ground upon touching his skin having
managed to survive the initial execution
kabimaru wonders why he won't die he
knows that he doesn't have any kind of
attachment to life as to his core he's a
ninja not someone who sees the value of
Life later on during a sentencing he's
visited by an inspector Who records his
life story in excruciating detail they
go over everything from his parents
dreams all of the attempts made on his
life how he actually wants to die and
finally how he was betrayed by his
village Chief lace later on and after
witnessing another failed execution
attempt the same female questions Gabby
Morrow stating that he told her he
wished to die and yet it appears as
though he just resisted his execution he
asks him why man with no reason to live
would do such a thing sitting there
Gabby Mario explains that he was the
best of the best in a wigakure and
because of this he was able to marry the
daughter of his villager's Chief however
after getting together he couldn't
tolerate her and requested a mating with
a chief to end it being restrained upon
entering to the house though the chief
states that he would allow gabimaru to
leave her but only on the condition that
he would complete one last mission then
out on that sin Mission the moment he
learned that he had actually been set up
he also realized that if he tried to
evade capture then the iwiga curry Clan
would track him down for the entirety of
his life so because of this he decided
to throw in the towel and give up this
coming forward to another series of
failed executions like oh my Lord the
actual insanity and pure beauty of the
art and the story is freaking phenomenal
like like look at this man after
surviving the Boiling Pot anyways any so
finally the inspector who had been
recording Gabby Mario's past tells the
other men around her that the
preparations are complete having
collected gabiamaru from his cell he
slowly walked to yet another room in
which he assumes that they'll fail
executing him again yet after opening
the door it's revealed that the female
had been questioning him is actually a
Slayer named Yamada Simon sagiri so the
simada a Simon is the name handed down
over generations to the Ronin from the
Yamada Clan who were known to be
extremely skilled with a sword and they
train their Blades by cutting down a
multitude of different people asigiri
prepares to bring her blade down on
Gabby Maru she tells him that his wish
is granted sensing death approaching he
realizes that this woman is indeed
genuine and instinctively flexes
destroying the shackles holding him
restrained quickly darting him behind
the ninja sagiri attempts to slice down
on him with a katana but Gabby Morrow
swiftly Dodges at the last second again
dodging a quick flurry of strikes from
sigiri Gabby Mario starts to wonder why
he's refused to accept his fate and die
as more thought of all start to surround
the duo zagiri tells him that they've
blade reflects one's true nature some
may Bluff and can be a brave face to the
bitter in some turn desperate and cling
to life While others deceive themselves
into accepting death to her it's
extremely obvious that there is a great
emptiness within him and it's fairly
evident given the life he's LED she
tells him that he does indeed have an
attachment to life stays here that he
loves his so-called dim-witted wife
tookabi Maru her very existence gives
him a reason to love in the first place
lunging at her gabimaro attempts to
slice a giri but she easily blocks and
confirms her Theory she wonders if he's
refused to be executed because he still
has feelings for her but he's also tried
to convince himself that he actually has
no reason to live screaming at her to
shut up Gabby Mark jumps back and yells
asking what the hell she would know
about this messed up world that they
live in he is the infamous kebimaru yet
as our broken man goes to scream the
name that brings Terror to the hearts of
even the strongest men he's cut off by a
memory of his beloved wife telling him
that he really isn't Hollow after all no
he's not the cold-hearted demon he's
made out to be he's full of kindness and
the only one who can stand to gaze upon
her deformed face after a small but
super cute moment together she says that
this confirms her there is no way that
he could actually be hollow inside yet
in reality now he continues to scream
that he is Gabby Maru the hollow a
completely heartless monster he tried
his hardest to live a freaking normal
life but it's just not possible living
somewhere peaceful a normal life like
Ordinary People he hasn't allowed any of
that all of a sudden though siguri
disagrees with a statement and presents
to him a document saying that he would
be pardoned for his Crimes by the Shogun
if he can play a certain task he would
have to travel to the other side
confused about what you mean by this
gabumaro asks if she meant death that
zagiri elaborates that the other side is
actually the pure land or Heaven A
revered holy realm since ancient times a
place of joy and Plenty when none will
suffer which has just been recently
found in the sea Southwest far beyond
the ryuku kingdom by the way this uh
ryuku Kingdom or like the islands that
the kingdom was in at the seat of
islands that hold Okinawa and stretch
down towards like Taiwan and stuff I
wonder if Taiwan could be the like
supposed land that they're referring to
here or I wonder if it's just a random
Island made up for the story but that's
quite cool to wonder if it could be part
of our own world in general anyway
anyway questioning the fairy tale-like
Story scary explains to him the emperor
of the selecture this Shogun had already
dispatched a research team to the island
however this single boat that had
returned was filled to the brim with
flowers and a foot with some organic
material instantly they sent out five
more boats but not a single person among
them ever returned as for the things
they did they could barely be called
human the Knicks came to head to the
island she'll consist of those already
Marked for Death so because of this
sargeria is here to actually recruit
someone she sees fit she seeks a man of
talent but someone still with a strong
will to live scary explains to Gabi Maru
that his wife is still alive but has
turned inwards from the moment he was
captured and now speaks to no one and
refuses almost every meal scary thinks
that only one can guess what's on your
mind but tells Gabby she suspects that
she's waiting on his return and so
because of all of this that have rambled
on about she asks him if he is still
attached to his life well he traveled to
this crazy ass island with a bunch of
goons to complete his pardon and return
to his wife as that is the only hope of
ever having a reunion with her standing
there with tears in his eyes as he
remembers his wife's words of
encouragement he asks sagiri if she
wanted to see some Ninja 2. then as she
responds affirmatively he tells her to
watch closely before Sparks of fire
start lighting turning Gabby Maro into a
ball of flames as he States ninpo
ascetic Blaze and an absolute blaze of
power Gabby Murrow effortlessly takes
out every single one of the surrounding
guards before taking the demoluchakuna's
place above a pile of scorched men and
confidently stating that she can count
on him he'll find the so-called elixir
of life going into a flashback now
sargeri remembers the first time she saw
her father skillfully executed criminal
so skillfully in fact that they don't it
didn't even realize realize what
happened from that day onwards she
wanted to pursue a career as an
executioner later a new life and after
completing her first clean cut she's
congratulated by the cloneless men
nearby sagira herself knows though and
is also reminded of her true weakness by
superiors each time she executes a
criminal it's explained that when there
is still fear inside one's blade their
doubt and fear will deliver an agonizing
death to The Condemned the blade
reflects the truth in all things a blade
drenched with fear causes the condemned
to suffer which in turn weighs down
one's blade even further being drowned
in her fear scary wonders how it's even
possible to overcome this how is she
either able to rid herself of this fear
and doubt like her father once had back
in the present day now we find all of
the law Breakers along with the people
who brought them to the capital seated
in front of the 11th Shogun Lord
Tokugawa narayoshi one of his goons
explains the confidential Mission being
offered to them as completed it will
give them a full pardon by decree of the
Shogun himself even still after telling
the criminals remove their blindfolds he
shows them the amalgamation of flowers
that had returned back from the land one
absolutely roped duties like nah nah nah
I'm out of here bro I don't want to
chill with these weirdos gets up and
goes to leave suddenly though his head
is cut clean off as at that moment the
same God screams some more information
informing every criminal that they the
Yamada asiamon will accompany them to
the island this is mainly due to the
fact that their death sentences are
already determined and they don't need
anyone trying to flee once making it to
the island the criminals are told that
if they make one wrong move or try to
turn once landed on the island then
they'll instantly be taken out then
finally just before ending this
explanation of what awaits them he
states that they'd like to cut down a
few other numbers tell any multitude of
Ruthless criminals to go on and reduce
the amount of participants as the
massacre begins filling the fat shocking
with Glee we see one young man who's
obviously on another level when it comes
to straight hands man takes out a few
small fries before it skips over to
akunuichi who by herself had apparently
taken down a bunch of retainers in the
segiwa castle the previous year Beck was
the Gary she's approached by Yamada
Simon Eisen who was that guy who Shanks
the father criminal just before anyways
as the two begin to talk he tries
discouraging her from partaking in
Emotion literally saying that she should
be in the kitchen not in the battle
which is just kind of crazy siguri
explains to him though that she would
have chosen that life if it was a
possibility but dear Clan test their
blades on bodies and turn the remains of
those fallen and to meet a sin so due to
these circumstances her life inherently
revolves around the dead and as much as
he tried to ignore it she just couldn't
as she knew from the time of her father
the blade reflects the truth in all
things a few criminals then try to
attack zagiri but fail as she manages to
decapitate them but just like previously
she's instantly dragged down by the
grotesque fear coursing through a blade
noticing this Gambino points out that
she's still Shake him when she takes her
life but State he'd rather avoid
unnecessary Killeen as to him that seems
perfectly normal have you never heard
this one of the guards points out to a
large group of criminals and commands
them to take down gabri Maru stating
that doing so will guarantee their
patient seeing as he had no other choice
and they met her now Gabby Mario
proceeds to brutally murk all of the
criminals trying to attack him after
saying the hollow himself literally go
demon mode scary comes to the
realization that instead of trying to
kill without fear she needed to try and
bear the weight of her fear and the life
she takes just like Gabby Morrow does
she sheds a single tear and declares
that she will be the one to execute
gabibaru so after the complete Beatdown
that we just got to Witnesses finished
the participants are finally revealed we
have this scarred up G Bandit King as a
chobay blade drag and Tamaya against Hit
susai Hunter of the hundred warped K on
everyone's favorite nurugai of the Sanka
The Killing Buddhist prayer harubo
strain ninja Gabby Maro the hollow
cannibal courtesan akagainu kunuichi use
a riha of keshu Moro Makaya the opposite
and finally the giant of bees in Roku
rotor remember all of these names along
with like each disciples from the Yamada
clan that will be appeared up with them
they all kind of get reveal field at
different moments throughout the early
moments of this island obviously anyways
anyways moments after the massacre was
completed all 10 survivors were loaded
onto a large ship and sent towards their
freedom supposed Freedom they would like
to think after arriving on the island
Gabby Morrow tells the Gary about the
iwuka Curry's Chiefs Immortal body and
how the elixir of life may actually
exist though he doubted it would be on
the island because of the unnatural
environment he then easily frees himself
of his restraints stay tuned that they
don't know what they could possibly
encounter but Sakira refuses to allow
him to do whatever he pleases and
demands that he put back on the
restraints not listening to her Gabby
tomorrow instead goes on about the
ridiculously small amount of supplies
along with little to no direction on
where to go once arriving stepping back
secretary holds a blade to Gabby's
throat and commands him to rebind his
hands she reiterates that they are not
Partners she is his executioner and
should he fail to find the Elixir well
she simply couldn't care less clearing
her voice she once again tells him to
bind his hands and watch after sign he
replies that he gets it and rebinds
stating that he'll go along with these
little rules but only up to a certain
point then out of freaking nowhere Gabby
Mario suddenly bends his neck back like
a snake dodging a thundering strike from
warped cayon having bounced back out of
the way Gabby Morrow instantly points
out to sagiri that they grow gabri
Morrow instantly points out to sakiri
that the criminal's arms were not
restrained which I absolutely love like
the instant rebuttal anyway overreacting
herself secretary questions the rank to
sort tested Yamada asymonkey show as to
why he wasn't following the rules
thinking that he's been ignored by the
hollow chaon charges it Gabby Maro and
pulls out a full case of weapons to
attack him with he states that the
weapons could only shine after they've
bathed in Blood and soon his entire body
will learn the beauty of his art Gabby
Mario who's just like Blown Away with
the weirdness of this new opponent
explains to him that if he keeps up with
how he's going then eventually the other
criminals will overtake him in his race
to the electure yet Keon rebuttals him
as he actually thinks it'll be a best
case scenario to take out all of the
other competition first being left with
no other choice gaming Mario decides to
take him out yet warped count instantly
charges them in a text with a huge
two-handed spear that shatters upon
connecting with the top part of his head
quickly he changes his stance and since
the collar is shooting back where they
jab to his body with a spear however it
had absolutely no effect on Gabby marrow
who led the legend hears was just double
checking to make sure his hands were
still tied together he then somehow
manages to pen his spear under his arm
and fling the giant upwards directly
above him while a bunch of the weapons
falling down he returns the falling
Weaponry that had just fallen out of the
Armory was some perfectly balanced Kirks
jumping back to Gary wonders if Gabby
Morrow somehow defeated him with one
blow yet Kion actually managed to
survive after revealing that he was
wearing a thick armor coating underneath
his clothing getting back up he states
that their legendary Hollow skills sure
are amazing but they weren't legendary
enough to pester his Living Armor he
appears to fight gebimaru once more
telling me small demon that he doesn't
understand the use of weapons and
couldn't display the beauty of his Blade
with his previous attack but now he will
teach him its true beauty yet apparently
this man is completely fodder and
doesn't even deserve three panels
explaining what happens as instead he's
instantly finished by these scattered
weapons that had fallen to the ground
just previously as Gabby Mario walks
away from the mess he Sighs and shows
the surprise retainers he never even
removed his bindings during the fight
over with the other group and while Roku
Rota was being transported which is like
the massive giant looking dude it takes
three vessels tied together to even pull
this giant along looking at the size of
him the random staff members become
worried overthinking the possibilities
that a giant could awake and go on a
rampage but Eisen this school's rank 1
assures them that this is literally the
reason they're here no one is immune to
their carts Beck of their main group
Keisha had actually moved into attack
and it's revealed that warped Canon was
taken by surprise being moved in the
process Judah was Prisoner dying keishu
advises the others that he's going to
hit home as he really doesn't have a
reason to stay anymore scary tries
warning him about the 60 men they were
missing on the island and help him with
finding them but these swordsman though
just finds it a complete waste of time
to be worrying about others and in fact
considers himself lucky to be able to
make an escape he warns her that the
criminals with them have already made
their move the individuals who have
never cared for society's laws and the
rules that the Shogun gave them should
not be taken seriously since it might
risk their chances of acquiring the
elixir of life in his eyes rather than
taking the rules literally surely the
Shogun it would be more pleased with
success at any cost he points out Gabby
Mario as a prime example asking if she
preferred he was cut down now and she
ran off having heard enough though Gaby
Morrow silences kisho getting it all up
in his face and telling her nothing else
mattered all he wanted was to get back
to his wife kisho tells him to hurry up
then and Snidely warns the hollow ninja
that within a few hours everything will
have changed back with Eisen and
probably had it somewhat of a similar
time seeing that the giant had written
he asks him if he's hungry but
immediately notices the bloodlust
emanating from his criminal any flash
they two didn't even trade word but
immediately go to attack sadly Eisen
ain't living up to the aura that that
name holds and was literally slapped
like a bug by Robin wrote her honestly a
complete change from all of the other
series with an Eisen plus with him being
rank one I was also expecting him to be
insanely skilled yet we never even get
to see his true potential obviously as
kisho then continues his ominous
statement it darts around the outskirts
of the island revealing the dismay that
has erupted and the other groups kishu
explains that apparently an emissary was
already headed to iwagakure to help them
with this Mission he knows the limits of
his strengths and tellsagiri that this
Mission will likely determine the next
head of the Yamada Clan then with him
having warned him about the coming
possibilities he finally makes his leave
taking this all in she tries to pass off
the idea that Gabby Maro would even make
a move to attack her however just as she
asks where they should go next Gabby
looking shell shocked dancer sagiri
trying to strike her down baffled and
angered with the change in his attitude
she just asked him why what could
possibly be the meaning of this standing
there Gabby Murray thinks back on the
moments after his birth and how his
parents tried to escape the village with
him but was sadly slaying the iwiga
Curry's Chief cruelly used this moment
to shape the child old telling him to
look upon their weakness he states that
because of his parents sentimental love
it made them weak and if he doesn't grow
into a strong man he'll end up like his
parents uncapable of protecting even his
loved ones later in life Back In the
Heat of battle and after learning what
Keisha had to say about iwakore getting
involved Gabby Murray knew that it would
all be over for him he won't have the
luxury of taking time and protecting
random people on his path to find the
Elixir and because of that he was left
with no other choice than to take out
sakiri dashing in the toilet loose a
flurry of strikes causing constant
Sparks to fly off the clashing pieces of
metal thinking herself said Gary wonders
why she's hesitating why hasn't she been
able to write him off as just another
villain opposing her Gabi Maru also
confused wonders why why is he wavering
before then remembering his wife's words
on how it's only natural that he doesn't
want to follow through with taking her
out instead it's best to follow your
sentimentality he's different now he
isn't the hollow man he once was it's
not a form of weakness but he formed
almost strength and it will guide him
into a pure Warrior unable to throw away
the beliefs he grew up with though Gabby
Mario can't help but fall back into
darkness knowing that he's learned of
weakness using his hand like a spear
Gabby burst or his bandages put into
Gary easily within range but once again
here's a taste allowing her to notice in
time and deflect the strike the two once
again slash at each other but they both
note that their own damn emotions are
slowing them down remember in the old
fart as though the dude has some kind of
hold over his thought Gabby Morrow takes
things up a notch proceeding to straight
up cut his sword in half and as she
stands there in utter shock seemingly
finishes the job yet somehow it's
revealed that zagiri had used his sheath
to deflect the killing blow momentarily
baffled Gabby just tells her they're
resisting that is useless as he knows
she can't bring him down with a sheath
alone he apologizes for what he has to
do however zagiri again hits a nerve
within him by stating that she didn't
realize he was capable of feeling such
sentiment given his reputation agreeing
that he doesn't gabimaru blitzed the
sigiri appearing on top of her in a
massive smoke and fire before he could
kill her though he is once again
reminded of his wife's influence and
stops himself from taking her out
appearing on his shoulder the chase
thoughts taunt Gabby trying to get him
to take out his retainer leaning over
her he tries to will himself to push
forth and do something he's done
thousands of times before but he can't
as his wife's operation is able to
destroy the emotions controlling home
laying below the broken man sargeri
realizes that throughout the entire time
she's known him he's won an expression
of utter pain like he was enduring
something for her she was able to see
this and it actually allowed her to
comfort the emotion she had kept hidden
with Gabby not being able to bring
himself to do what he needed to do he
begins crying believing that with the
way he is he won't be able to survive on
the island or ever see his wife again
sigiri though realizes that this isn't
weakness what he has is love for his
wife what shows for a fact that he can
feel emotions still lying there she
promises him that if he faces his
emotions while reclaiming his life then
she will support him throughout the
journey finally security hell's Gabby
Mario to show her what he's capable of
as even though their inherent
relationship hasn't changed he is no
longer the same man he once was ah so I
absolutely love these next two
characters to get introduced throughout
this part of the story here complete
Polar Opposites but uh damn they're both
so cool in their own kind of way so in
the past the hulking giant gents usai
went by the name blade Dragon eight
provinces unparalleled after arriving in
a certain Province a daimio who shared
the similar title offered him work and
food so he decided to take him up on the
offer after a couple of drinks though
the daimio insisted that even with his
nickname he doubts he could ever take
down an actual Dragon utterly insulted
with the idea that he couldn't take down
a dragon against usai destroyed the
dragon statue atop the entrance way to
the damio's residence along with the
whole gate obviously as you like may
have suspected this resulted in him
being kicked out of his own Clan and
sentenced to death hence how the man
ended up on the mission here to the
island having revealed his past to his
retainer who's the rank 9 Yamada asiamon
Fuji
tells him that once he gets his pardon
and walks free he will return to cut
down that Celio daimio's Mansion Fuji
who's just standing there utterly fails
to comprehend how even came to that
being a good conclusion gintitsu's side
jokingly mocks the tiny retainer and
makes a few negative comments about the
Yamada Clan paved though he draws out
his sword and tells him to not make fun
of the clan causing gentichusai to back
away from the blade filling a deadly
bloodlust coming from the midshires not
escalating the argument the big man just
tells him to not get in his way before
freeing himself from his bindings he
then explained his part of eliminating
the other competition around criminals
wise so he can take the extra time with
finding the Elixir and safety Fuji takes
note that only a few criminals will
survive the trials on the island and if
the Shogun becomes impatient because of
that he will call it Connie stronger and
more venomous batch of Warriors to be
dispatched in their stead by the way
this is like a big thing in the story
here and I hope some people pick up on
it like throughout just let me know down
in the comments if you do and whatnot
but the symbolism here is actually taken
from real life back in early Japan they
used to put venomous insects in a pot
and then let them battle to the death
which is absolutely crazy then they will
take the Venom that remained and use
that to curse someone another big
mangaka to like go out of his way and
actually do this in their series if
you've noticed is gigo atami or some of
the recent stuff and the manga like
chapter 215 that uh this is reference to
but yeah anyway continuing continuing
either way having moved forward together
the toothing stumble upon some ancient
man-made statues not paying attention to
her surroundings against your site is
stung on the hand by a random looking
butterfly that had a human face on it
stunned he quickly remembered what
happened to the guard that have returned
from the island and without a second
thought cuts off his hand confusing the
retainer with him looking at his hand
though at Sean and a matter of moments
after having landed on the ground it
started morphing into a bunch of flowers
suddenly from within the trees around
them butterflies start bursting out
causing gantetrusai to get excited as he
prepares to defend himself against the
random creatures however appearing from
behind him once more a comically large
titan-like creature then starts walking
and their Direction meanwhile Gabi
marrow and sagiri are also approached by
the same weird-looking creatures what
they're confused over what they're
saying Gabby Morrow steps forth telling
sagiri to stay back looking at it he
wonders what in the world it could
possibly be why a fish it doesn't even
look like it's supposed to be real plus
it's got these random prayer beads as if
it's subject to some sort of religion
with his instincts screaming danger
Gabby Mario watches as the Beast tries
to attack him easily he's able to dodge
the amalgamation of hands before jumping
up and kicking the monster however the
monster was actually able to block the
blow then having grabbed the Ninja's leg
proceeds to toss him into the ground
causing Gabby to jump back and rethink
his attacking strategy remembering his
Ironclad ninja lore number five to avoid
an unfamiliar enemy he thinks about
fleeing the area with sargeri yet our
boy is taken by surprise as a rope like
extension from the monster grabs and
tosses him through the nearby foliage
wounded from the blow he tells akiri
that they just need to run for now but
as they go to leave it's shown that a
plethora of these random monsters with
prayer beads Investments have surrounded
them seeing No Way Out Gabi Morrow
clears his head of all other
distractions and goes utter demon mode
jumping into the sky he easily takes out
their monsters with a punch before
igniting them with an info ascetic Blaze
sagiri who's watching in horror behind
him remembers how Kevin Maro explained
that in his clan they go through all
kinds of bizarre training and through
that their own abilities akin to
breathing fire or becoming one with a c
kebimaru having sparked a light from the
use of his technique knows that in order
to survive this hellish Island and get a
pardon he has to kill anything that gets
in his way watching Gabby Morrow fight
off the random creatures siguri thought
that she was prepared to take on the
unknown but now with everything going on
around her she starts to wonder if
perhaps this isn't the pure land but
instead then before she's even able to
think any longer a large bottle-like
monster confronts her from behind Gabi
Mara who's fighting in and out of some
kind of like visual experience notices
that zagiri is in danger but instead of
turning to help her focuses on taking
out the large creature and front himself
however without even realizing it Gabby
had managed to actually attack her
creature saving zagiri in the process as
Gabby sits there confused holding her
she thanks him for saving her life but
then again out of nowhere he has his
head wrapped up by one of those
creatures tender calls randomly and he
split seek him before the Monster
Squeeze down someone had managed to see
for its hold on Gabi Maru turning around
he notices that three newcomers had
arrived and saved them from the
surrounding creatures use a riha who's
another ninja like Gabby walks up and
makes her introduction whasagiri thinks
it's odd that a pair of retainers are
escorting her Kevin Morrow thanks them
for intervening but asks why why would
they go out of their way to help someone
when they're under no obligation to do
so yusu rehire just try straight up
seducing them to get around the question
and entertaining up however getting
marrow pencil down explaining that that
method won't work on him be like Gabby
guys don't be like sneako don't be a cut
boy like sneaker anyway anyway yusu riha
was really trying to team up with him
but before they could continue as a
group sigiri asks why would two people
who scored her rank a Yamada are Simon
Genji explains that he was originally in
charge of Morrow yet Morrow was quickly
deceived by user riha and taken out
after realizing what she'd done Genji
proudly determined that she could not be
left alone with just a single
executioner and decided to watch over
her with the other dude usury here
explains that before Renea to Gabby Maro
they were also surrounded by bugs she
knows that this island isn't exactly the
safest place and because of their nose
fighting The Elixir and escaping is key
yet if she was to run him without a plan
all by herself she'd probably be killed
and it would all be for nothing so due
to the predicament she found herself in
the strategy of playing it safe by
teaming up to find the Elixir is by far
the smartest after thinking Gabby Mario
accepted her into the group yuzuria
tried giving him a hug but Gabby
instantly pinned her down again telling
her that he wasn't in agreement since he
didn't trust them any slighthurst
looking at him yuzuria breaks the
Ninja's hold pulling him in close and
telling him that they didn't have to
trust each other and can betray each
other whenever they'd like as after all
the Elitches just with a single pardon
if they team up though she'll provide
them with information regarding the
human face butterflies explaining that
they swarm around the monsters and have
scales and emit poison that cause
hallucinations but I still in mystery
overall curious on how she figured out
all this to start with Gabby asks how
she came to this conclusion funnily
enough like remember Morrow from just
before well yusu riha had got hella
friendly with him like she tried to with
Gabby then tied him up to a tree then
you know let him pray to certain bugs to
check their effects from the she was
able to learn that the centipedes by far
have the worst effects but the majority
of the bugs won't really attack you
unless you provoke them Yamada are Simon
seemed her who's like originally usury
has executioner finally speaks up and
lets them know that all of the monsters
he's seen had qualities associated with
Buddhism and Dao those two religions
alone have fundamentally different core
structures so he finds it weirdly
unsettling that they're Blended together
on some sort of dark nature from Justice
fact alone he believed that this
Island's true nature is definitely not
pure zakiri agrees like even though
these monsters appear as Godly beings
the feeling who played gives her
solidifies the idea that they are simply
living creatures to use a rehur this
just to means that this is a priority
they communicate and gather more info
but get me Mario wondering what's
motivating her to this extent asks why
according to her this is all for a
little sister she suffers from an
incurable disease and due to her
situation in life they couldn't even
afford basic medicine in an attempt to
earn money she turned ninja and took
part in hella's training inside of the
kai Clan randomly one day the boss
turned on her and that's how she ended
up here still Gabby Mario doesn't
honestly doesn't believe her finally
revealing what seems to be the truth
though she says that she doesn't even
have a story you need to live and return
home as more than enough for her wanting
to know one more thing Getty inquised as
to what exactly she did to her
executioner like last time she insists
that it was just used as a vessel to
perform research experiments on before
Snidely asking if he really cares that
much about the lives of others now in
that she contains information about the
island Gabby Maro agrees to help her
with fighting but other than that
they're not cooperating as the others
then Becca about what information to
share sigiri looks back on how far she's
come since arriving on the island which
in her eyes is pretty much nowhere she
knows that she was overwhelmed by the
monsters and the entire situation itself
has just caused her to feel flustered
disappointed in herself for how
powerless she currently is scary drops
to the floor fainting from the effects
of the previous battle going back in
time again slightly I guess were
introduced to Toma who'd managed to earn
his license as a part of the asymon
executioners after only a month of
training the only thing remaining for
him to do was the execution itself
funnily enough it's shown that the
person he'd chosen was his own brother
in a tune of events that the clan isn't
even privy to yet Tomah had purposefully
infiltrated them so that the two would
later be able to escape together
obviously the way they ended up escaping
or trying to was taking part as a
retainer and criminal when they trip to
Paradise Island now on the island at
Sean that the two are able to make
landfall But like everyone else had been
surrounded by a plethora of random
wildlife and religious figures watching
chobe rushed forward to protect him
Thomas thinks back on how even when they
were little and had lost their mother to
illness even after their father betrayed
the clan and was sentenced even when the
bandits attacked them without a second
thought chobe always figured things out
and adapted to every situation he
learned early on that the law of this
land isn't the strong always win but
rather a survival of those who managed
to adapt best to their situations and
surroundings affecting them by the way
you'll learn all about how the story
teaches us that being strong and weak
are both valuable to someone's
personality it's a much deeper story
than like I really thought when I got
into her I came in under like the
president that it was a darker Shonen
and puddled like the dark Trio with CSM
and JoJo K and it went crazy with some
of its battles but I had no idea that
some of the things that it tries to
teach us as its readers are truly like
good moral to live by like straight up
even with just Gabby being faithful to
his wife even though he is only 16 and
not that pervy weirdness that other
series tend to have like it's that
faithful love it's it's normal anyway
let's get past me being like that weird
soppy normal diavolo in a different
timeline I don't know where the
steervola came from but anyway moving
forth having taken out a bunch of the
monsters that you will notice even more
approaching and decide to flee the area
rather than take them on as they try to
escape Thomas here is caught by one of
the monsters and while freaking out
screams for his brother's help however
Toby continues to run off leaf with no
other option then to defend for himself
Thomas strikes at the larger monster
trying to take it down bombing through
the monster though it's shown that Toba
had actually just gapped it to grab a
large Ax from one of the previously
defeated creatures chobe is then struck
by another monster taking him completely
by surprise and while looking at the
group beginning to surround him adheres
them all tell them that killing is a sin
standing there listening to all of the
voices Echo around them Toby begins to
freak out and a similar way to scary
earlier chobe on the other hand though
like man's on that demon mode spec
becomes enraged by the speaking of sin
and tells them to shut up up he screams
as he destroys the surrounding monsters
that all of them are just slaves silly
puppets stuck to a regimented code of
lore unlike them he is his own Master
his own God standing there looking at
her brother Tomah admires Toby's ability
to adapt his constant unyielding sense
of self is what defines him so when it
comes to like the overall plan with the
brothers right here it's changed from
just getting this pardon and escaping
together now chobe states that he will
kill all of these monsters and criminals
on the island before down in the elixir
of Life themselves back with uh the main
Squad now Siri awakens terrified after
having a nightmare that involved her
father looking down on her Genji who's
nearby looking after her while the
others were working brings her up to
date on how they've actually taken
shelter in a tree Hollow and she had
fainted because of the toxic powder
coming off the butterflies as sagari
then leaves the hollow she finds Gabby
chilling outside with seem to making a
meal for the group outside he brings her
up to date explaining that while looking
for ingredients for their meal he took
the opportunity to check the island out
a bit more pretty much he was able to
deduce that there isn't anything
resembling The Elixir around the area
they find themselves in instead most of
the fauna around are like a jumble of
different plants that you could find on
the mainland with the exception of a few
random flowers Genji suggests that the
plants might be from the ryuku islands
but Gabby explains what really stood out
was how all of these Samurai were in
bloom remember like the initial Squad
that rolled up to the island was only
one returning well yes sadly they'd all
Fallen prey to this island as you could
probably Imagine by the way if like
anyone confused with the ryuku islands
again and you go karaku's Story the
islands are probably like the closest
pace of Japanese land to the so-called
Paradise Island Center like the old
school weeb legend himself then gives
his input and tells them how these
statues all scattered about the place
seem to be either Buddhist or Taoist in
design yet that isn't actually what
intrigues him more he questions at the
technology to create such things even
exist on this island or perhaps their
creator lives elsewhere before he
brought them here scary believe said
it's just unfasable for anyone to live
on the island to start with since the
creatures make it too dangerous for any
human to exist she then explains how she
detected human traits from the monsters
when she was cutting them but detected
no signs of organs or reproductive
capabilities the Monstrous forms are
utterly bizarre within possessing some
form of humanoid structure but with bugs
and other creatures riding atop them
Center interrupts and explains it all a
little bit better we know that they're
religious in nature but the details
aren't exactly right as if they poorly
thought out deities this island and the
Monsters as a whole it's all too
artificial to be the creations of divine
creatures it is of the group had been
tossed into an ill-conceived mandala an
unfamiliar space with nothing tying and
back to reality go any crazed expression
gavimaru becomes manic after hearing
their creatures without organs exist to
him that sounds like some form of
immortality so if he can find that
Source then he can return home taking
Gabby Morrow's advice seemed to say is
that they should do more research on the
monsters before they travel any deeper
and put their lives and more danger as
the sun begins to start setting Genji
confront sagiri and demands that she
returned home on his shirt he knows that
this isn't a place for her and due to
her criminal passing away can take her
stead in her eyes anyone who decides to
stay on the island will only face death
but zagiri denies his attempts to send
her home instead watching to complete
her Duty Genji questions her skill
though and points out that the blade she
now has is just some random one she
picked up along the way to anyone in the
Yamada Clan they know that the katana is
a warrior spirit and with siguri having
lost hers and says if she's already lost
what made her a Yamada to begin with he
doesn't deny that she is truly skilled
with a blade but this island is
different some weird skill is needed to
win battles here and she's clearly been
held back by one majorly defining Factor
her Jinder this feels some weirdo
masculinity Vibe coming off Genji right
now he seems really cool up until a
moment ago it kind of kind of sucked I
like his uh bushy ass eyebrows either
way meanwhile the goats themselves Rank
10 Yamada or Simon tenza and his
criminal guy are found on a small rowing
boat attempting to escape the island
naruka brings up that even if they do
manage to leave they'll both die as
they've returned without the Elixir
thinking that he can get his way through
any scenario tenza reassures him that
he'll try and convince the higher up
somehow once they have bought the Shogun
a sherb apparently there is a large
vessel that is meant to be anchored
nearby for three days allowing them to
complete the mission and their return
home on their vessel after pointing out
something he thought was the boat they
both disheartened to only find the
remains of this ship strewn in between
long ago destroyed ships half submerged
in front of them naruga who spotted
something out of the corner of his eye
tells tenza to stop drawing his sword
but it's too late as a massive tentacle
appears behind and swipes out the two
having noticed in time narugu was able
to grab his boy and Dodge the attack
telling him that most creatures are
sensitive to shiny things so they should
just look for an Escape Route unable to
find a boat to escape on the two become
surrounded causing the ruga to think
back on the time he accidentally leads
soldiers to his village back then he was
one of the mountain info someone who
didn't pledge loyalty to the shogunate
but instead lived traditionally with
Japan having certain roles in this time
period that meant people couldn't live
this way they were instead considered
Rebels against the regime sadly they
used narugai to lure out the locations
of his other family and clan members who
subsequently died from this once
imprisoned himself naruga had met tenza
who out of the generosity of his heart
offered him a mission to search for The
Elixir as a way to escape imprisonment
confused on what he should do naruko
wonders if he should die for the cynical
method or live on and continue his
villager's bloodline as the last of its
name obviously as we find him stumbling
into keisho's body which had become
blooming with flowers had chosen the
letter and decided to take his chances
with tenza on the island as a massive
tentacle destroys even more of their
surroundings narugu looks upon kishore's
body and sees a vision of his
grandfather's last moments causing him
to become frightened and drop to his
knees tinsa asks what was worrying him
but naruga utterly broken after the
decisions he'd made in his life note
that it really makes sense now all of
this is just a Divine punishment his
true sentence for causing the deaths of
everyone he holds close as they tend to
call bees down upon the duo tenza was
likely able to slice it before it took
out the Rue guy and after listening to
his explanation about the Shankar's
people's Customs tells him that he
doesn't care about the Customs he
believes in he just needs to survive
with more attacks pushing tenza to his
limit he screams that he doesn't want to
hear about his grandpa or the village
the real question is if you want to live
or not thinking back to a peaceful time
in the mountains with his grandfather
urugu says that he doesn't want to die
and instead just wants to return home
Throne of my sword then tenza points out
kesho's boat telling him to survive as
they fight their way off the wreckage
teaming up now that you are just barely
able to battle their way through the
monsters and make it safely to the shore
of Paradise Island aboard kisho's boat
from the efforts to escape the island
tenza was able to deduce that even if
they find the Elitch here it's pointless
without a weight off the island he
points out that one boat did manage to
make it back to the mainland so there is
some sort of a Escape current but as he
turns to look at nauru guy he notices
something yes that's right I fooled you
all or at least I hope I didn't give it
away because it's actually revealed that
while they're washing up tenza noted
that neruga looked extremely feminine
twitch naruka says that he is indeed a
girl shocking the assignment with a
massive reveal out of the way and the
two funnily joking around tenza says
that moving forward they have to scout
around to find a proper Escape proves
but the monsters also pose an issue so
he proposes the idea of searching for
more allies that also was to return home
which and my eyes makes perfect sense
plus I think naruga is another really
dope character it's funny how we've got
a Yamada who looks like a chick and
Tomah and a criminal that look like a
dude and a real guy kind of just
opposing factors on each side and in my
eyes goes into the entire theme of Yin
and Yang that later gets spoken about in
much more depth back over with Genji
who's really Keen to make a point on how
this ain't no place for a woman and
scary needs to take a boat back when
Dawn arrives half wanting to leave
herself and half not seem to believe
said it would be the best choice for
sargeri to leave but also thinks that
she should stay to watch Gabby Maru from
what he's saying so far he can say
without a doubt that Gabby Mario was not
the same man as he was back at Edo it
may only be because he knows that he
needs to return with her but wonders if
there is also some other reason keeping
her here with him with night fooling
around them now sargeri decides that
she'll watch over the group as they
sleep but Gabby Mario tells her that he
literally doesn't sleep so there wasn't
any need to stay up even still he asked
if she was feeling better as he
suspected that after he wounded her in
their previous battle the poison from
the butterfly probably sped through a
quicker due to how she helped him see
the light he realized that rushing in is
only going to result in disaster for the
group from now on they won't run from
anyone that threatens their chances of
survival or the possibility to reunite
with his wife they'll meet everyone head
on turning to zakiri he also compliments
her believing she could be even stronger
than himself as obviously he doesn't
have a knife a strength reflecting back
on the time with her only prison he
states that even then he'd felt his
story strength they're the same backing
out boys Village one cannot know one
strength without first traveling far and
wide most people don't even realize
their full strength until they're forced
to act it's that way for everyone as
Dawn then finally begins to rise sakiri
becomes encouraged by Gabby Murray's
words and faces Genji telling him that
she appreciates his concern but will not
leave the island the flipping knob Genji
finds this ridiculous as This Woman's
only role should be to Bear a child for
the Yamada Clan having heard that same
thing a million times before sagiri
explains her grief growing up telling
him on how everyone including her father
looked down on her for following the
path of a warrior and that now a fellow
klansman was doing the same she urges
Genji to look at her as a samurai to
acknowledge that this is the path she
took man or woman regardless of
someone's situation they should always
be free to choose their path this
absolute Doge though like Genji what
happened to you dude who hurt you
obviously man is angered by his
statement saying that this isn't the Way
of the Samurai he draws his blade and
goes to strike down on her however as he
stands there talking smack it's revealed
that secure had managed to disarm and
steal his blade completely perplexing
the bushy-eyed freak literally taking a
dump on this man's head siguru reveals
that Genji was originally the person who
taught who had a Steely blade in the
heat of battle Genji gets him even
murder screams again that a katana as
the Warriors Soul yet unlike sir Gary
He's unable to notice Roku Rota
approaching them from behind
during his time as an infant Roku wrote
her head I think like accidentally
killed his entire Village and family by
pushing over a tower of stones he built
sending them shooting off like bullets
around the area at least like I I think
that's what happened it looks like
that's what happened back on the island
now Genji had managed to turn in time
but just like during his childhood Roku
Rota used the infamous Palm strike to
connect with the samurai sitting him
spinning back severely wounded siguri
runs towards Genji but is about to be
attacked by the giant luckily for her
Gabby Murray arrives on time landed a
fat he'd kick to Roku Rota sending him
crashing back through their surroundings
noticing their eyes and Roku wrote his
retainer wasn't with him so Gary comes
to the correct conclusion that he had
been taken out as soon as they landed on
the island Gabby umara quickly goes over
the two options Escape or fight that
ultimately decides to take on Roku Rota
and tell sigiri to leave so that she
isn't in danger dodging a massive tree
that takes out a few more behind it he
then looks towards user rehearse who's
Big chilling up in a tree nearby were
Center and asks for her assistance user
rehear though was like nah it reminds
him of the deal providing Intel while
Gabby Mario deals with the fighting Rojo
Rota strikes at Gabby marrow once more
but he easily manages to jump back out
of the way and begins to strategize on
how to handle him his insects tell him
it's utterly impossible to guard against
his hand if he hits him it's game over
trying something different he Stomps the
ground causing a few rocks to fly out
before using nympho's Stone synonym of
stones into the body of the massive
brute in front of him what he
projectiles not working he uses nympho
and formed blade and goes to strike Roku
wrote her yet his attack is quickly
deflected Once More by the hand not
knowing what to use he decides to throw
a couple more range attacks but as you
can see by the like what even is that
one two three seven abilities used on
the hulking giant but a single one
worked lydian Gabby completely confused
on what his next course of action is
meanwhile in the forest behind them
security tries to save Genji which is
like my girl even Genji who's still on
that weird gender Spiel finds it strange
that earlier sagiri had the attitude of
a man but now hosts the compassion
vision of a woman screaming Adam
security says that it doesn't matter
what she is she doesn't want to see a
comrade die with that said Genji finally
accepts some sort of Enlightenment and
realizes that zakiri's conviction was to
accept both sides understanding who she
is now he brings up his sword and gives
it to her to fight Roku Rota and instead
he screams at her now that if she's a
so-called Samurai then she won't
hesitate to cut down Roku Rota taking
Vengeance for him and Eisen over with
Gabby it's obvious that he's still
struggling with coming up with a
strategy to fight Roku wrote her but
notices that zagiri appears and swiftly
cuts off one of the Giant's fingers it's
said that anybody no matter how sturdy
or unconventional it is can be cleaved
the principles of execution will never
change you just need to know the body's
framework and worker to find your own
openings standing there together now
both Gabi Morrow and zagiri get ready to
take down Roku Rota together still big
chilling up in the tree nearby user riha
watches the two face off against Roku
rotor cinta who's currently penned up
and the tree branches asks to help PNG
but usury here tells him that it's too
late and is much safer to stay up in the
tree watching the fight down below Gabby
Mario tells you Gary that it will be up
to her to finish him off with a singular
cut sargeria informs him that in order
to do so she needs him on his knee since
the Nick is up too high but already as
Gabby Morrow says that he can pull it
off Roku Rota throws a thundering punch
towards Gabby but he deflicts it with a
kick leaving her with the perfect
opportunity to drop the giant sagiri
Gets behind Roger Rota and while
remembering her past mentors prepares to
cut his right leg however stops just
before connecting and jumps back as a
thundering backhand comes through it's
shown that she wants to avenge her
Fallen comrade so bad that his swordplay
is wavering and becoming unsteady trying
to compose herself she barely Dodges a
punch directed at the duo Gabby Maro
himself realizes that he can't deflect
too many more of these strikes as his
league is already beginning to suffer
siguri tries to cut Roku Rhoda's arm but
fails once again noting how his massive
size and his fighting style is causing
his bones to interfere with the blade
Roku rode his stomach then loudly
rumbles causing him to start crying and
screaming almost stiffening everyone
around gamingara goes to block the noise
with his hands but as soon as he does
the giant takes the opening and slams
The Hollow into the ground darling back
up almost immediately Gabby tries to
withstand the unreal level of strength
and almost does but sadly succant for
the head and drops to the ground
panicking now he's screams at himself to
get up as it wasn't a fatal attack
though if he doesn't move soon he'll be
annihilated by the next one coming to
his Aid so Gary gets in front of his
next attack but quickly realizes that if
she doesn't move as well she'll die
telling herself to calm down suppress
your emotions and be rational as she has
chosen that way to live so curious able
to figure out that there is no
distinction between the two and
accepting both emotion and reason will
allow her to move forward unlike other
members of the Yamada Clan sakuri hasn't
seen enough battle to make her a true
Soldier but when she's on a mission and
her goals and spirit a line when Oliver
delts leave her blade whose swordplay is
unparalleled once the insane bout
finally comes to an end it's showing
that zagiri was able to drop the giant
onto his ass she quickly darts him
behind him attempts to deal the
finishing blow but just as quickly as
she got in behind Roku wrote a sprung
back realizing that the next attack
would be fatal seeing as how normal
moves weren't working Gabby Morrow comes
up with a normal plan but tells his
partner that it may be slightly extreme
after analyzing the situation Gabby Maro
pulls up his clothing over his face and
bursts into flames taking out some balls
Gabby uses nimpo acidic Blaze mode to
send them shooting towards Roku Rota who
just knocks them away following up he
combines and then posed Eiffel wave and
Blaze mode to send some Flames towards
the giant then using another multitude
of techniques Gabby Morrow attacks the
giant of bees in over and over but his
opponents somehow manages to repel every
single attack over with user Raha who
decided to Gap it earlier knowing what
Gaby Mara was actually planning tell
cinta that Gabby wasn't actually
targeting Roku Rota no he was going to
burn down the forest and use the smoke
to suffocate their opponent once these
smaller branches and leaves all light up
the whole area will be covered with
smoke that creates a canopy concentrated
overhead but bit of a science lesson
here for you guys so uh smoke is made up
of carbon monoxide carbon dioxide and
particulates matter what actually
affects us is the carbon monoxide as it
binds with the hemoglobins in our blood
even more readily than oxygen this
causes the body to instantly be deprived
of air hence when most people in fire
start a carbon monoxide poisoning not
the actual fire itself back in the
battle and due to the effects Roku Rota
falls to his knees giving securian
opportunity to finally strike him down
Roku Rota notices her and tries to
retaliate but gabimaru rushes in and
holds down his hand his screams of his
teammate to hurry up as his muscles
can't hold on for much longer hearing
this and becoming tranquil yet intense
sagiri becomes one with her blade and
swings The Sword Down
and his final moments Roku Roto
remembers his past wandering aimlessly
searching for someone to play with
obviously from what we've seen with Roku
Rota like I'm not going to let this
action slide or anything but it's fairly
evident that the dude has the mind of a
child and never actually grew up either
way sigiri apologizes to him and lays
his soul to rest telling him that nobody
resents him anymore
as the fire begins to get closer Gabby
says that it's probably best they leave
in case the fire attracts unwanted
visitors while running away siguri
remembers Genji who's actually still
wounded racing up against the tree
nearby though after realizing that
she'll also perish if she returns makes
a wise decision to leave telling herself
that she must accept both her strengths
and weaknesses which I'm like yo I think
sargeria is on to something you hear
with a strong weak thing if you are
ordinary I'm actually on my second read
through of the story now which is why I
have a little bit more information than
I usually do say with like the Jujutsu
Kaizen videos and stuff but um if you
didn't know from 2016 to 2018 Yuki
actually worked as an assistant with
tatsuki Fujimoto on Fire Punch before
beginning this series later in 2018 so
it's dope to see that greatness breeds
greatness and to be honest I don't
necessarily see similarities between
their Works obviously like they're a
part of the dark Trio but I just love
knowing that these goats had worked
together in the past and now that
they're blowing up in their own kind of
way it's really really cool as expected
all of the nearby monsters are lowered
towards the flames which is already
starting to die down due to the thick
level of mist and humidity around the
island gabumara suggests hitting the
direction that the creatures actually
came from as despite his injuries
they've really got no other choice if
they want to find leads about the elixir
of life as they start to leave security
asks that they should just take a moment
to recover but Gabby Morris that's
freaking out and claiming that it
doesn't matter how dangerous it is they
just need to find the Elixir and make it
back to his wife he asks if zakiri is
worried about all of your other comrades
but she states that everyone who took
this Mission took it knowing the insane
danger that it held having consumed for
them would only answer Gary's ice
dishonor their resolve as she has the
time to worry about them then she also
has the time to be searching for the
election as a way to free them from this
hellish Mission hearing this Gabby notes
that it seems as if they're finally on
the same page and while running soon
catches up to Yuzu riha and Center who
has stood there in shock looking down
upon something coming up behind them
both Gabby and sigiri noticed that the
others had found an abandoned Village
since it comes to the conclusion that if
they are truly in shinsengkyo the
village must be worthy human live which
if I haven't mentioned the island as
shinsenko it is the Japanese name for
the ancient Chinese version of paradise
populated by Immortal gods and Mountain
Hermits hence how Center has gathered
the information for Hermits living in
these so-called Villages and like the
the reason that Santa just has so much
knowledge with everything that's going
on right now is because this era of
Japan or like the the time that it's
situated in with this story is time
where like art and knowledge kind of
flourish throughout Japan more than it
had done in the past few hundred years
because there was so much fighting and
stuff going on between different parts
and with the Shogun and Emperor kind of
thing going on it just led to a lot more
research and a lot more growth inside of
their own culture anyway enough of me
nerding out about like random history
stuff heck with the uh brutal Brothers
like I absolutely love these two guys I
almost forgot this happens here but
Tobago's full beast mode and begins
eating the various Monsters of the
island as a form of fluid to stay
hydrated which kind of makes sense when
you think about it while this is going
on Tomer explains to him that there is a
possibility fictional beings called
Hermits reside on the island they're
based on the old Chinese mounted Hermits
but despite the old age they're actually
Immortal beans that wield Strange Magic
shinsengcho is really meant to be home
to these Hermits and not monsters so
Tomah wouldn't be surprised if they ran
into them here Trevi jokes that he'll
just turn those old fools into another
meal though as they move deeper into the
foliage of the Jungle Toma notices
something or someone nearby getting
closer at Sean they're in an opening at
of a fallen statue two beautiful women
are basking in the sunlight with all
four of them noticing each other
simultaneously one of the random girls
that taught this statue wonders why are
humans here they come in a rage that
they thought that the social Guardian
deities were slacking off so his Center
suspected all of those creatures seem to
be some form of poorly thought out
deities created by someone either way
back in the standoff here Toby readies
himself were pointing out that the girls
are probably another form of monster one
of those apparent monsters Snidely asks
that they would like to lay with them
causing the brothers to get Hella
confused by what exactly they meant the
other one stands up and literally
changes into a male while cursing them
out over having lost his solidity he
slams his hand closed causing the fruit
to explode and letting the brothers know
that they must die
so that there officially brings us to
the very end of this first part of this
new series that I'm doing on the channel
the island arc from yukikaku's jigo
karaku or hell's paradise whatever you
guys want to like call it obviously
those are both its names English and
Japanese honestly the series is so in
fascinating with the themes that it
tries to show its readers and like the
manner that it's kind of like portrayed
in throughout the the story like
visually and all that kind of jazz like
I expected this when I got into the
story but I actually I really never knew
how well it was actually weaved in
throughout the art itself for example
I've bought up the Dow and how the Yan
and yang have a massive role in the
series but have you noticed that each
character almost has a corresponding
color that opposes them in some kind of
way like I know I know it's just black
and white here obviously but you have
every everyone like in a way has that
one person who has a corresponding black
to their why I'm quite interested to see
what the anime does and that same aspect
if it matches up to their affinities and
the colors that it's given their
characters you know like clothes and all
because obviously there's no colored
version of the story that's legitimate
or like there's no colored version out
bit that I was able to find sadly so I
don't really know at this exact moment
and the affinities and all that kind of
jazz like that gets revealed in this
next Arc that I'm going to be hopefully
getting out within two weeks if you guys
smash that like button and push this
video to 5K likes and I will work my ass
off to do it but that there gets all
explained in much more depth and that
it's like I think that that Arc alone is
like probably gonna be around three
hours two and a half to three hours long
just by like looking at it right now but
this uh next Arc is honestly really dope
because things picked up and they were
pretty heated in this first kind of art
here with all the hands that happen and
that kind of jazz but it's second dark
but we finally get introduced to all of
the tension is absolutely insane like
like it's absolutely dope the fights uh
topped here the like manga art by far is
probably some of the greatest that I've
read in a while like it add definitely
dwarfs Jujutsu Kaizen and Chainsaw man
with like just these stylistic choices
out of the dark Trio it's definitely the
most beautiful of the three and like the
uh the man himself yukikaku was actually
given the opportunity to post like the
story on Shonen Jump Plus to start with
just for the fact that he was already an
editorial like staff member at shueisha
beforehand and the person there felt
like his story was so beautiful that it
deserved a like a role automatically on
Shonen Jump Plus by the way moving
forward if you guys have enjoyed this
video then obviously check out my
patreon which I will leave a link to
down below which helps support me like
throughout those massive weeks where I
can't upload like this one here
obviously and if not just hit that
subscribe button and leave a like on the
video either way as it really does just
help out with like pushing my content to
a bunch of new amazing people and of
course also smash this video to 5K likes
and I'll work my off to get that video
out within the next like two weeks
hopefully but anyway enough of that for
now it's been your professional
degenerate diavolo and LC wall enable
bye